[Music]
hey you guys
happy tuesday yeah i know pookie was in
here sitting in daddy's chair
yeah i walked in here and i just so said
i'm gonna sit there and start sitting
down
she's like no no sit on me daddy daddy
wouldn't sit on yeah so um
we got something to show you guys yeah
you want to do that first you want to
talk about the movie first
let's go let's go ahead and just do it
so we finally got well we can we can do
how many we got in there right now
only seven we'll talk about it once we
start talking about the movie then
yeah like i said put that down i'll put
that right down there i haven't even got
a really good look at it yet because we
just got it
we watched a pretty fun movie last night
it was kind of like a uh
old school early 80s um
kind of like was his name carpenter
style
horror movie but a comedy but a comedy
horror
yeah but it had a 80s carpenter style
soundtrack and everything uh you know
with the score
it was pretty good it's fun it's kind of
was low budget
well made um
all kind of like on location looking
stuff and it was um
kind of like filmmakers doing going back
to like their punk rock
you know what i mean it's like a punk
rock type
you know productions they're what they
used to call that back in the day when
they were just running around new york
without licenses and just oh yeah what
was the name kind of like that a little
more polished up
just um fun you know kind of like some
of these newer horror movies that you're
seeing
you know low budget horror movies that
are well written kind of well made but
you could tell it's a budget this one
was actually a lot of fun
uh so this is a canadian movie uh even
though i think at the beginning it was
supposed to be set in michigan
ah now it makes sense yeah not only was
that
like a carpenter's style soundtrack it
was also kind of like old west's name
the uh um what that fucker's name you
know what i'm talking about
no cronenberg oh okay yeah it was kind
of i could see there was some homage in
the cronenberg there
in the in the score yeah but in the
tradition of
uh many canadian movies they try to make
it seem like it was set in the u.s
so it's actually supposed to be set in
michigan in 1983. well cronenberg did
that too sometimes
well that's what i mean so a lot of
canadian filmmakers did that i guess
like to make the movies more universal
it's like no they're totally we're not
it's not a canadian movie it's like they
put little american flags everywhere and
[ __ ] yeah i think they did that with
black christmas they did that because i
think a lot of people don't even know
that black green that made sense
there was a bigger market in the us yeah
sure yeah but yeah so so it's a canadian
film even though it's
supposedly set in the united states
doesn't really matter because michigan
and canada are so close anyway
i think it was filmed in ontario and uh
the writer direct well the co-writer
director is cody callahan
who i think um he had worked as a
producer
like i guess for on a lot of horror
movies a while he's directed a couple
other ones
i think is probably his best known one
before this was anti-social
this movie which is called vicious fun i
think was it you tammy that recommended
this one i remember one of you guys uh
recommended this one because shutter
just added it
and i think it premiered at maybe the
glasgow film festival
last year and you know obviously it's an
indie movie so it didn't really get
um you know a wide release or anything
like that but shutter just picked it up
like a week or two ago
and i'd been hearing a lot of good stuff
about it so i really really wanted to
see it
and it in indeed is uh a really lot of
fun what a great
premise also so the premise of this
movie and also i'm not spoiling anything
too much because this was in the trailer
so there's this kind of like douchey
incel
type dude who writes for a horror
magazine back in 1983
and he's one of those you know he's one
of those well actually [ __ ] and
[ __ ] like that um and he has a
crush on his roommate but she has
friend-zoned him
so he um decides
that he's going to essentially follow
and stalk this douchey guy named bob
that she's been dating
um and it so happens so he follows him
to this chinese restaurant
he gets completely completely [ __ ]
hammered
ends up falling asleep in like the
cleaning closet of the restaurant and
gets locked in there overnight
and when he comes out he stumbles across
what is essentially a secret meeting of
a self-help group
for serial killers yeah and so
they all think that he's this particular
serial killer named phil
who's supposed to be at the meeting so
he has to pretend
that he's a serial killer to avoid
getting murdered
it's kind of like an aaa meeting for
[ __ ] serial killers yeah it's funny
i mean like i said what a great [ __ ]
idea the look and the feel of the movie
and the sound of it
just kind of like the general tone it
reminded me a lot of vfw
if you like vfw you'd like this yeah i
mean everything in this is like
everything is like neon
lit and like really really saturated
colors it looks really nice
yeah and the score is fantastic
i loved the score of this yeah so
if you and you know vfw was also kind of
like a carpenter homage
yeah this one you know car carpenter and
cronenberg were friends and a lot of
their movies kind of had it
they kind of borrowed from each other
sometimes they they were influencing
each other so
this one kind of now that i've now that
i know that it's canadian i'm seeing the
the cronenberg influence it's like a
it's like an homage to cronenberg and
carpenter but it's a comedy horror
yeah and i really like that all of the
serial killers
have their own kind of styles they're
all kind of either based on
sort of loosely based on real serial
killers or loosely based on like movie
serial killers
like the one really big huge dude that
guy was in mandy i know he looked
familiar
but the really big huge dude who was
basically like your jason voorhees type
with a machete and everything who liked
to kill
girls at sorority houses yeah that type
of dude
then you had like this really you know
justin bateman you had a justin bateman
type of
who's the bob character uh who's the
first one that you meet
you had this little creepy like german
accountant dude named fritz
who also liked to dress up as a clown uh
he was played by
uh [ __ ] man uh julian richings he was
that guy last time he's been a lot of
stuff but the last time i saw him was in
that other shutter movie uh anything for
jackson he's like a real weird looking
dude
and he was kind of like the real creepy
like
um guy that would prolong the deaths and
he had like all these
records and everything and then you had
like your kind of
military guy that was kind of like or he
wasn't like military he was like a
he was like a what do you call it like a
black ops type of dude that would like
go and wipe out whole villages you had
that kind of guy then you had this girl
named carrie
and then you had um who has her own
thing going on
and then you had hideo who was like a
chef but also a cannibal like you know
what i mean and he had kind of a samurai
thing going on
so you had like all of those and it's
interesting because
for a while like the scene where he's at
the
meeting and he's trying to blend in and
he's just like this total dork and he
just like is
totally in over his head and he's trying
to do that and i thought that that was
kind of going to be the whole movie but
it goes like to different
places so it kind of went in some places
i didn't expect
there's also like uh one act that a long
act in the middle that takes place in a
police station which was very assault on
precinct 13
if it was a comedy um because the cop
characters in that were like super funny
and they had like the big
cop mustaches and stuff and they all
thought they were hot [ __ ] and they were
just like completely useless
and it's just like it's it's just a
really really fun
i think though your enjoyment of this
movie
will hinge upon um because the
the guy that plays joel who's the main
character
uh his name's the actor's name is evan
marsh he was actually in
shazam i think he played like the bully
kid um
and he's like he's a very annoying
character but he's supposed to be
annoying
so and i found him a little bit grating
at the beginning but i kind of warm to
him
and he has like a really good character
arc like through the whole movie
so i think that was a lot of some of the
criticism that i saw was like oh they
thought the character was too annoying
or they couldn't get into it but a lot
of them did kind of like warm to them
later on
so i do kind of feel like that will
maybe uh
color your enjoyment of it but overall i
thought this was like a really really
fun movie like i laughed out loud like a
bunch of times at like some of the gags
and it's like it's homaging a lot of
other horror movies but
not in a real obnoxious way you know
what i'm saying i enjoyed it
yeah i thought it was super fun in terms
of homaging and other horror movies like
i said i put this right there with vfw
i don't want to call it a vfw rip-off
but tonally it kind of was
it is similar in tone to vfw yeah i give
it more vfw i like vfw better
but this one's good too i mean it's not
like you know you can't watch this one
because you like vfw but yeah it's just
you know
it's it's it's the same type
this one's a little bit funnier than vfw
but it's not as gory like vfw was way
more over the top
this one's got gore in it but it's not
as crazy or quite as like violent as vfw
vfw was trying to do it like straight
carpenter early carpenter yeah like
along along the lines of like halloween
three
well that was crowded burke but uh yeah
when that was cronenberg right
no no who was it who did halloween three
i can't even remember now
because there was some stuff that kind
of what would be another good uh
carpenter movie to put
vfw on like uh like scared from new york
yeah about like san antonio will road
says what's vfw that was a horror movie
that came out when did it come out two
couple years ago 17 2018 something like
that about of uh a bunch of grizzled
old war veterans like in a vfw and they
have to fight off a bunch of
well there were some young ones too
though yeah that was the young ones too
he just showed up during the vfw and
they were fighting a bunch of drug
addicts
yeah it was outside of like a
dilapidated city
it might be probably supposed to be
detroit or something
but there was some kind of an old
abandoned buildings across the street
that had a bunch of
a bunch of drug dealers and a whole
bunch of but they're real stereotypical
like
punk rockers from the 80s because that's
what they used to do back in the age
yeah it was like it was
it was an 80s so much like a loving 80s
yeah kind of like kind of like they were
kind of like the people from escape from
new york
the the new york prisoners from escape
from new york yeah like that
and uh they attacked the vfw because
they killed one of their dudes and
[ __ ] accidentally got the drugs so
they were in there trying to get the
drugs that's just a big
action horror movie this vfw
uh bar getting swamped by all these damn
drug addicted
punk rockers and all the veterans trying
to like fight them off and very fast
yeah and it's like super fun it's that
one's super fun too super fun super gory
like really really violent yeah it's
kind of a situation
kind of like uh imagine if imagine if
carpenter was doing night of the living
dead because they're in this place
trying to keep them all out they're
coming through the windows and [ __ ] it's
pretty good
but yeah so yeah so it's like a similar
tone to that like a vicious faunas like
i said it's not quite as gory there are
some like some out eye gouging some
people's intestines
coming out and [ __ ] like that so it's
like you know and somebody gets
strangled with intestines so that's
always fun
um i think probably my favorite
character in this was the was
bob the character that's kind of
supposed to be like american psycho you
know what i mean uh yeah
this is supposed to be the patrick baby
um ari millen is the guy that plays him
he's in a [ __ ] ton of stuff uh he's an
orphan black he's in a bunch of stuff
uh but he just like he seemed to be just
like having the [ __ ] time of his life
playing that role
well this would be a fun movie to to act
in yes i mean he seemed like he was
having a blast
the tone is not real serious yeah
they're just
i mean the one scene where he puts the
[ __ ] jukebox on and then starts doing
this bizarro like dance to it i just
like laughed my [ __ ] ass off
and he's well his thing too is that he's
like
uh he's like a chameleon he pretends to
be like
different things like to get victims you
know what i mean like he's pretending to
be like a real estate agent or he has to
be a
fbi agent or something like that so he
can like go into different
uh you know personalities and modes and
stuff so that's kind of like his
strength as a serial killer
but yeah it's just like this was a super
super fun i mean if you like horror
comedies
you definitely should watch it and
especially if you like kind of throwback
ones because
it had that 80s like neon look to it
uh had that really nice like uh [ __ ]
retro wave [ __ ]
retro wave score i mean the score of
this was so so good
and honestly like every like i watched
several other horror channels reviews of
this and every single one of them was
talking about how [ __ ] awesome that
score was yeah retro 80s [ __ ]
motif it's becoming real popular with
these low-budget
um horror movies and they're they tend
to be pretty good
yeah i mean yeah and well the thing
about it like i said
it's not only just because everybody
like
a lot of younger people now like like
the aesthetic of the 80s yeah it's all
cool but also
because when you're making a horror
movie it's much easier to go back to the
80s before we had cell phones where we
had this that the other thing
so it was like so much easier to make a
scary movie when you didn't have all
that technology that would
you know that you'd have to like write
around it right um so i can see why
that's kind of happening to you
yeah and if there's a computer it's like
a little apple 2e type computer big old
you know what i mean it can't it can't
help you much
yeah yeah tammy says what is it on it's
on shutter
and it might not i don't know if it's on
any other streaming platforms at the
moment because it says shutter original
on it which usually means that they have
i think that means that they have like
exclusive rights to it for
x amount of time um they just added it
about a week ago
you might be able to find it somewhere
else but i'm not really sure but uh yeah
that's where it came from
so yeah definitely check it out if you
like uh funny horror movies because i i
had a good time with it i thought it was
like really funny okay so let's go to
the reveal people are asking about
the damn cookbook reveal there it is
jenny this is my this is the proof i
just
we just got this like an hour ago so i
haven't really had
much chance to look through it yeah uh
to see
like what it but it is hardcover it is
yeah
how many times it is 168 pages i think
it's 168 pages
there's the back there putting all the
little kitties yeah
and every page is um
photo packed now the only thing that
came out that i didn't
i didn't realize that it would come out
this way i wanted everything to be
in english measurement and in um metric
yeah i kind of forgot to do that i
remembered to do fahrenheit celsius
yeah uh but i forgot to do magic but i'm
looking at the i'm looking at the way
it's it's written out
if you were to put the metric next to it
it would be a lot bigger it would take
up a lot of room
can we see look
everything's in cups and tablespoons
you know what i mean all the
measurements but yeah these are all this
actually came out really nice i never
used
it before they can't see that i know
well i'm looking through for a page
that uh that i can show
and i kind of like i was going to go
with the gloss but
one it was like way more expensive and
honestly i kind of like
matte more than gloss i don't know why i
think i don't like gloss because you can
see all the [ __ ] fingerprints on it
that drives me faster yeah
you know people were going to be cooking
around that and if if matt saves them a
couple bucks go with the mat
that's what i'm saying well yeah because
um the thing about it was that
uh the matte paper which was like a
little bit heavier right
um it made the book cost like dollars or
some [ __ ] like that i was like yeah no
i'm not doing that
okay why don't you read off uh the uh
everything that's in there
in terms of uh well now i'm not gonna
read every single
recipe because there's like a zillion
sections the
the biggest section is just the american
section
that's mostly like southern soul food
type stuff
um you know there's a couple other
things thrown in there too but that's
kind of like we
we also did like big thanksgiving dinner
uh and all the sides we did that
then there's also a central and south
american section
so that has mexican brazilian all that
kind of stuff
uh some cuban is in there too because i
didn't have anywhere else but
um there's an asian and indian section
lots of indian food some chinese food
some thai food
yeah now that some korean a little bit
of korean
yeah and now the the chinese and the
thai
are not authentic chinese and thai it's
american fast food
yeah yeah chinese and thai what you're
used to what you're getting here in the
united states
it's a lot easier uh to execute
uh you know what i mean the gringo
versions of those
dishes you can get the components yeah
it's easy
everybody knows the sweet and sour and
[ __ ] that's just easy to make yeah
and then there's and then there's a
small section that's like italian and
more because it's mostly italian
uh because pizza is kind of one of your
things yeah that you do so you talk
about how to make the dough and the
sauce and everything
and then there's like a lasagna eggplant
parmesan and then we had like a couple
of like greek
things and then like a couple of like
hungarian like hungarian paprikash and
stuff like that because you make that
all the time too
there's an elvis tribute with fool's
gold in there
um crystal sandwiches yeah and then the
last section is drinks and desserts we
have
some cocktails and we have like
different cake pie cookies
all that kind of stuff um and like i
said pretty much everything in there
in here is stuff that we make on a
fairly regular basis
yeah or we at least make every now and
then yeah and there's photos of
everything
and we put photos of everything i bought
all the photos i didn't want to like
because i was no you can't do a photo we
were gonna
take some in here but they just never
come out that good but
photographing food is like near
impossible it's very very difficult
usually when you're seeing photographs
of food that's not food
a lot of times it's it's something else
like vanilla ice cream is always crisco
yeah um because it's like you know
colors are all wrong tomato sauce
can't be photographed very well there's
some more that's there's some brazilian
stuff there
you know so it's like it's all kind of
like fun fun stuff
in here so what do you think it'll what
do you think it'll sell for i think i
have to check because i think that
more or less it's probably be like 35
about 35 bucks something like that
between 35 and 40 something like that
because like i said when i had it set up
like with all the glossy pages i was
showing that show them the drinks
when i had all the glossy pages uh they
were like yeah the book will cost like
70 dollars i'm like yeah no let's not do
that
let's not do that it's like i'll do the
map page there's the lord kukulkan
there yeah that's a part of the drink
section here got mojito in there how to
make that
mojitos yeah got all kind of slick i
took some pictures of tom doing silly
[ __ ]
yeah there's a couple pictures of me in
here too like some couple pictures of
the kitties
like on i think on all the fish dishes
yeah i put little pictures of pookie
going give me some of that yeah
it's got pookie and pookie in in the uh
in the book
yeah pokey is on the book couple laying
on her back she's laying on her back
looking at you crazy i have one picture
of her doing that i can't remember what
page it's on
where the hell is it it was one of the i
think it was one of the like fish dishes
so it must have been like probably in
the american section but it's like
pokemon says that's gorgeous jenny
thank you very much what's my signature
dish oh man
everything i do is a signature dude
that's hard to say it's like i mean
people would say well yeah see there's
one little picture of pokey right there
where she's kind of on her back yay tuna
that was a picture i took it for a
little while back where she was like i
was like a silly oh
that's what i was thinking speaking of
pookie she heard her talking about her
she heard her name she's like candy man
you say her name and she shows up
yeah hi sweetie she's looking for
something yeah you want look you're
famous you're in the book
she's like i don't care i can't read so
um
so that's the reveal for that we'll
probably be plugging that on the main
show
yeah i'm gonna have to go in and see if
there's anything else that i have to do
like to make the sale public you know
what i mean because sometimes you have
to order a proof first i know for some
sites you have to order a proof
and then you have to look at it take the
time and double check it again oh i'm
going to
that's why i was like really because i
wanted to see it like i went over the
digital file like a zillion times
yeah but seeing it in print is like
always something different it looks like
they reproduce the colors like
exactly so that's really good okay um
well i mean you know they but i did it
too
so go me because i worked
i've worked in printing most of my life
so i'm like pretty aware of the problems
that can arise yeah she worked for a lot
of
a lot of the big alcohol companies
worked for um newspapers
magazines magazines uh direct mail
companies
i worked for a place that did that made
um
made [ __ ] for conventions like you know
those big like glass panes with like
[ __ ] logos and designs and [ __ ] on
them i worked it for one of those
so whenever she whenever she makes books
they're professional
productions yeah i mean i try to get
them i try to get them
it was social media and doing audio
books that really took us
took us uh uh time to figure out you
have to do that on your own
yeah um because that's a that's an
ever-changing
plug-in technology right there you know
what i mean and then you're dealing with
other companies that have
recording standards that you have to
live up to and finally we got that right
it took us a while to correct the audio
book ah that took forever yeah and i had
to buy a 300
microphone i don't i can't even use this
one well you can but it doesn't it's not
quite the same
it's harder yeah so yeah i had to buy a
scarlet solo which is in there and
that's like 300 something dollars
for the audible because they don't you
know they won't accept it
and then there's like audio [ __ ]
sound boxes that's got to go through to
clean everything up and everything
yeah controls well actually i found
somebody on the internet because the
internet's a wonderful place sometimes
had had made like a a script that if you
run your audio files through it it will
automatically
um put it to the parameters that audible
as long as it's a good file to begin
with okay i mean it can't be like a
piece of [ __ ] it won't fix it
um because you know it's garbage and
garbage out generally but if it's like
good enough it's close enough and you
run the script on it it'll
it'll it'll put it within the parameters
and it should like and it should fly
but what was weird is when we started
the show we started the show as a
vehicle to sell the books but it turns
out that the show makes more than the
books
yeah i mean i still make money on the
books but a lot of it comes from live
streams now
i mean yeah i mean the show really is
kind of like i mean between my three
things that i do like my three jobs
essentially um
pretty much the show is what like half
and then you know
books and graphic design is like the
like is like a quarter each
yeah something like that of like it's
just
uh you can't have one you can't have one
[ __ ] gig you gotta run [ __ ] five
of them simultaneously
even shirts helps out yeah i mean
everything's sure every little thing
helps out
you know what i mean and on honestly
stuff like this even though this
cookbook and i
i feel bad because i wanted to have it
done like before christmas last year and
i didn't even get close to doing that
um because it took forever but i wanted
it to look really good i wanted it to be
correct um you know so it took me a
really long time and when it's
our stuff that we're working on um
i'm really really a perfectionist and
i'm super paranoid that i'm gonna like
have a
i'm still paranoid that i'm gonna look
and there's gonna be a [ __ ]
typo in there and i'm just gonna cry
yeah if i see it
you know what i mean it's like gee i've
only read through this book like 40
[ __ ] times but it's like
it's you always miss something yeah but
you know what we're doing is the same
thing big companies do they they're not
one trick ponies either they have to
have a diversified product line and
that's really all we're doing
yeah and that's that's how you do it and
that's going to be
the future economy for a lot of people i
think you know
because there's no centralization
anymore yeah
saying which is a good thing it's all
getting democratized
there's no gatekeepers you can jump in
and run your own [ __ ]
show and if you're good then you you can
survive it's sink or swim
there's no security no security well
that's true you're working for your life
yeah but you get used to it though tell
me about it yeah i kind of i came up
that way though
even as an independently contracted
salesman it was just if you didn't sell
then you weren't going to eat you had to
sell
and you just kept out there [ __ ] uh
banging on it and banging on it and
banging on it until you made the sales
that you needed
you know same thing hooker does
[Laughter]
want a party okay don't need company
don't give it away we
got money we gotta record that later
yeah yeah yeah
well everybody i think everybody's here
is patreon so they probably know that
yeah because the move your retrospective
hey want to party it's franken okay yeah
right yeah
we just have to uh we have to record it
like after we're done streaming here
yeah so all right so yeah if you have
shutter
uh and you like horror comedies this is
definitely one that's worth watching
so uh and especially like i said if you
like retro 80 [ __ ]
then uh check it out and like i said
i'll let you guys know when
this goes on sale if it's public or
anything like that because i gotta go
check with lulu and see what's going on
with that because we just got that
camp guys princess print ads my trade
show display
looks like a sixth grade boys social
science project project
well you can always contact jenny and
she can do a [ __ ] fantastic job for
you
she works for several people doing that
kind of stuff yeah i used to i
i work for one guy that he uh sells his
stuff
in stores and i have to make all the
displays
like for the product to go on yeah i do
the product package too but then i also
have to make
like the big display that they go on
this goes abc always be closing yeah man
glenn gary glenn ross yep
[ __ ] right exactly i was the one i
was that kind of a salesman
didn't still didn't sell that same
product but it was that same
high pressure sales technique and high
pressure sales only works when the
customer does not detect the pressure
yeah everything's just gotta be well
yeah if somebody's like jumping in your
face going by this you're like yeah
charming and smooth and talking you know
it's between us
right your wife doesn't have to know
about this does she
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well you know what i'm talking about it
just like
because a [ __ ] will run well i
have to talk to my wife
who wears this enhancement i knew that
was coming
a matter of fact why don't you just give
me your wife's number let me call her
give me your point all kinds of [ __ ]
ways you can start
you find a crack you start [ __ ]
making the crack wider and wider and
wider and you get in there
let's just go ahead and take care of
this now come on man put the pit in the
hand and let's get out of here
come on i got [ __ ] all right i know you
need this
i'm gonna hook you up don't worry about
it that's only money
big shot like you come on man it's only
money
[Laughter]
all right so uh yeah so i guess we'll
wrap it up for today thanks everybody
for dropping by as
always uh tomorrow's wednesday so drop
by at 5 00 p.m eastern standard time for
our
drunk ass sidetrack show who knows what
we'll be talking about it'll be
something fun
yeah and we won't remember it the day
after but uh
you know all right so uh have a good
rest of your day you guys
and we will talk to you guys tomorrow
evening bye